bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat à suivre ce matin à
l'examen au sénat du projet de loi de
programmation des finances publiques
pour la période 2014 à 2019
un texte qui a été adopté par
l'assemblée nationale en première
lecture le 21 octobre dernier un texte
qui a pour objectif de fixer les
dépenses et les recettes pour l'état la
sécurité sociale et les collectivités
territoriales pour les cinq prochaines
années et c'est clair très clair la
france va devoir se serrer la ceinture
les collectivités notamment sont dans le
viseur avec une baisse programmée des
dotations de 3,7 milliards d'euros
c'est un sujet qui fait grincer des
dents ici au sénat puisque les sénateurs
représentent constitutionnellement les
territoires l'examen de ce texte
intervient également une semaine après
la validation par bruxelles du budget
français mais aussi et surtout deux
jours après les prévisions très
pessimistes de la commission européenne
sur l'évolution de la france la france
qui deviendrait selon la commission
européenne toujours le mauvais élève de
l'europe avec un déficit à 4,7 pour cent
en 2016 loin très loin de la promesse
des 3% tout de suite donc on prend la
direction de la séance m
1 la présidente madame la présidente de
la commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs le projet de loi de
programmation des finances publiques
définit les grandes orientations
budgétaires que le gouvernement vous
propose pour le cinq ans à venir
ce projet de loi définit également de
nouvelles règles de gouvernance des
finances publiques pour améliorer la
gestion publique et instaurer les règles
nécessaires au respect de la trajectoire
budgétaire gouvernement vous propose
donc un ensemble cohérent qui poursuit
un objectif
l'assainissement des finances publiques
en fixant des objectifs est redéfinie
sans de nouveaux moyens pour les
atteindre tout d'abord chez vos créé la
trajectoire trajectoire qu'au
gouvernement vous propose est une
trajectoire de poursuite de
l'assainissement budgétaire le déficit
structurel est devenu avec la loi
organique du 17 décembre 2012
notre repère principal pour évaluer
l'évolution de nos comptes et entre 2011
et 2014
ce déficit structurel a été divisé de
moitié pour atteindre son plus beau son
plus bas niveau depuis 2001 pour les
années à venir le gouvernement vous
propose de poursuivre sa réduction pour
atteindre l'objectif de moyen terme en
2019 proposons effectivement de décaler
de deux cents le retour à l'objectif de
moyen terme par rapport au programme de
stabilité qui nous a été présenté en
avril dernier
ce décalage s'explique par deux raisons
d'abord par prudence
par souci de simplification la nouvelle
trajectoire de solde structurel est
fondé sur l'hypothèse de croissance
potentielle de la commission européenne
cette hypothèse est plus basse que celle
de la loi de programmation en vigueur
elle vient donc minorer les forces
structurelles en dépenses et donc
l'amélioration du solde structurel à
montant d'économies constants deuxième
élément l'inflation est également été
revus à la baisse
cette révision a mécaniquement un impact
négatif sur l'effort structurel en
dépenses même en maintenant le même
montant d'économies cet effort est
mécaniquement diminué du fait de la
révision à la baisse de l'inflation ou
plus exactement du déflateur du pib
derrière ces considérations je vous le
concède un peu technique
il existe une réalité la france et avec
elle la zone euro traverse une période
prolongée de faible inflation et de
faible croissance
c'est un environnement économique
exceptionnel qui n'avait pas été
anticipée et qui non seulement pèsent
sur la croissance et l'emploi mais
également pour effet de ralentir
l'amélioration des finances publiques
nous avons pris acte de ces évolutions
économiques et après avoir mené une
réduction drastique du déficit
structurel en 2012 et en 2013
le gouvernement propose de ralentir la
réduction du déficit structurel tout en
la poursuivant naturellement pour
adapter le rythme d'assainissement des
comptes à la situation de l'économie
comme vous le savez le gouvernement a
annoncé de nouvelles mesures pour 2015
pour un montant de l'ordre de 3 6
milliards d'euros
vous aurez à vous prononcer sur ces
mesures dans le cadre de l'examen du
projet de loi de finances et du projet
de loi de finances rectificative qui eux
vous examinerait prochainement
ces mesures ne modifie pas
fondamentalement la trajectoire qui vous
est soumise ce projet de loi
elle devrait avoir un impact de l'ordre
de 0,2 point de pib sur la trajectoire
de déficit
et c'est donc une modification limitée
des orientations proposées par le
gouvernement par coordination avec les
votes sur le plf et le plfr le
gouvernement vous proposera donc en
nouvelle lecture des amendements pour
intégrer finement la trajectoire et au
rapport annexé l'impact de ces mesures
supplémentaires je voudrais évoquer dans
un deuxième temps les mesures de
gouvernance
ces mesures de gouvernance me semble
essentiel pour améliorer la gestion des
finances publiques jean représenteraient
les principales l'article 22 du projet
de loi de programmation propose
d'instituer une revue de dépenses
annuelles
chaque année des thèmes d'investigation
seront définies et les constats et les
conclusions de ces revues ou seront
transmises avant le 1er mars
sur cette base la procédure budgétaire
qu'elles soient administratives ou
parlementaire pourrait être alimentée
d'idées de propositions qui enrichiront
les débats et permettront de poser
clairement les enjeux
l'article 11 fixe un objectif
d'évolution de la dépense locale car la
dépense locale fait partie de la dépense
publique elle a un impact sur le sol de
publiques et les objectifs que fixent la
représentation nationale concerne aussi
cette dépense cet objectif propre à la
dépense locale sera exprimée en
comptabilité générale
il permettra de servir de repère pour
apprécier la progression des dépenses
des collectivités locales
chaque année il fera l'objet d'un avis
du comité des finances locales et à
partir de 2016 nous proposerons de le
décliner par strates de collectivités
l'article 12 reconduit le principe d'une
mise en réserve des crédits de l'état et
d'assurance maladie pour assurer le
pilotage ses dépenses au cours de
gestion proposons d'ailleurs d'augmenter
à 8% sur le taux d'augmentation 8% le
taux de réserves sur les crédits hors
personnel car la réserve créé une
pression vertueuse sur les ministères
pour les inciter à gérer au mieux leurs
dépenses de l'année enfin l'article 29
bis adopté à l'assemblée nationale
initiative de l'assemblée nationale
renforce l'encadrement des partenariats
publics privés en mettant en oeuvre une
recommandation de vos collègues eu
portelli et jean pierre sueur
cet article vise à obliger les
opérateurs et les hôpitaux à recourir à
l'expertisé des services de l'état
lorsque ces organismes souhaitent
recourir à ces types de contrat qu'il ne
prend plus signer directement
il prévoit également le principe d'un
avis non liant des services de l'état
sur les projets de ppp menées par les
collectivités territoriales
dans les deux cas l'objectif est de
centraliser une expertise sur des
contrats dont les enjeux financiers et
juridiques sont souvent complexes et
peuvent ne pas être métisse maîtrisé par
tous les organismes publics
ces différentes règles de gouvernance
vont permettre d'améliorer la gestion
des finances publiques
à chaque loi de programmation elles sont
complétées je crois que nous avons
atteint aujourd'hui un corpus de règles
qui a permis de renforcer nettement les
bonnes pratiques au cours des dernières
années
ce président mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs ce projet de loi de
programmation des finances publiques
poursuit l'assainissement des finances
publiques je les dis et cette réduction
du déficit se poursuit dans un contexte
macro économique dégradé
c'est la raison pour laquelle
gouvernement vous propose de ralentir le
rythme par rapport à 2012 et 2013
mais au delà de la trajectoire de ces
hypothèses ce projet de loi prévoit
également les bonnes règles de
gouvernance qui me paraissent
indispensables à la bonne gestion
j'ai d'ailleurs constater que votre
commission des finances a mené sur ce
point un travail approfondi sur les
articles gouvernants je suis donc
persuadé que nous aurons un débat de
qualité sur l'ensemble de ce projet de
loi
merci le seul ministre monsieur eric de
montgolfier rapporteur général de la
commission des finances à la parole
monsieur le ministre la présidente
mes chers collègues comme vous le savez
ce projet de loi de programmation
comporte deux parties s'étaient dit à
l'instant par le ministre une première
partie sur lequel j'avais un petit peu
insister sur laquelle je le dis
clairement nous sommes en désaccord
qu'est la partie sur la programmation
des finances publiques est un ensemble
de règles de gouvernance sur lequel nous
aurons en effet je l'espère un débat de
qualité
là nous allons sans doute pas proposé le
rejet des articles parce que nous
pensons qu'ils attendent de de règles
qui peuvent être améliorées qui
contribue pour certaines à l'information
du parlement et donc je pense que nous
aurons en effet des échanges j'espère
que nous pourrons parvenir à un accord
sur un certain nombre de dispositions
qui nous paraissent aller dans le bon
sens notamment celui de la bonne
information du parlement vous me
permettrez si vous le voulez de dire
quelques mots
par contre de la trajectoire puisque
comme vous le savez ce débat s'inscrit
dans un contexte qui est riche en
rebondissements puisque ces dernières
semaines ont été marquées par un sound
échanges entre le gouvernement et la
commission européenne
malheureusement on peut le regretter
nous avons surtout est informé de ces
échanges par voie de presse si on a plus
d'informations en lisant le journal que
à travers les échanges avec le
gouvernement et souvent il s'agissait de
spéculations concernant le sort qui
pourrait être réservé au budget de la
france au ce stade nous avons
semble-t-il éviter le désaveu mais mais
la vie la commission européenne qui sera
rendu public d'ici la fin du mois ne
risque pas moins d'être stress sévère en
tous les cas face à une situation qui
risquait en cas de bras de fer prolongé
de mettre en péril la ville stabilité de
la zone euro et le crédit la france il
fallait pour le gouvernement comme pour
la commission ne pas perdre la face et
il ya eu donc des échanges un peu
compliqué qui vise à donner à centre de
gages à la majorité et à donner un sens
donc de signaux l'égard de l'union
européenne je pense à des réformes
annoncées comme celle des professions
réglementées
en tous les cas pour éviter le pire le
gouvernement a donné l'impression d'être
prêt à faire tous à l'exception d'une
seule chose des économies
supplémentaires eh bien oui on va en
parler puisque l'annoncé d'un effort
supplémentaire de 3,6 milliards
d'économies aura sans doute permis de
trouver ce compromis qui permet au final
à chacun de sortir la tête haute de
cette période de tension qui s'est
déroulée loin des regards mais la
décomposition précise de ces trois
milliards 600 millions d'économies n'est
pas connue et pas plus tard qu'hier j'ai
interrogé le ministre sapin en
commission nous y étions et nous l'avons
demandé le détail et malheureusement il
n'a pas été possible à ce stade clients
le détail on aurait d'ailleurs peut-être
souhaité avoir un amendement ce matin
qui corrige la trajectoire pour intégrer
ses 3,7 milliards d'euros
il sonnait en tous les cas pas des
économies structurelles qui sont sans
doute la constatation d'un plan
d'économies peut-être notamment sur les
taux d'intérêt en tous les cas il y a
peut être aussi des augmentations de
prélèvements obligatoires qui sont
certes ciblées sur des petits points en
tous les cas il n'y a aucune réforme
structurelle dans ses 3,6 milliards
d'euros
alors nous avons c'est vrai sans doute
évité le pire le pire c'était quoi
c'était la crise de la zone euro
s'étaient l'abaissement du du crédit de
la france
avec l'augmentation des taux d'intérêt
mais force est de constater que les
règles de gouvernance budgétaire qui ont
été mises en place à la suite de la
présente crise ne sont pas grandie ne
sortent pas grandies de cet épisode
à vrai dire même si le gouvernement n'a
cessé de plaider sa volonté de respecter
les traités ces règles en sorte
sérieusement écornée et on pourrait se
dire après tout cela n'est pas si grave
cela ne serait pas si grave si nous
avions été exemplaire et cela n'a pas
été le cas
alors sans prendre temps je vais vous
simplement vous rappeler le petit
historique récent des différentes
renonciation du gouvernement qui montre
comment il a en quelque sorte jouer
jouer peut-être chat et la souris avec
la commission européenne
après avoir annoncé mais je vais
commencer en 2012 pour ma part après
avoir annoncé sa volonté de renégocier
le tsc j'ai pendant la campagne
présidentielle le président la
république il y a rapidement renoncé
puisque comme vous le savez il a proposé
à travers la loi organique du 17
décembre 2012 de transcrire cette
renonciation
quelques mois seulement après son
élection il s'adressait aux magistrats
de la cour des comptes c'était à
l'occasion de la rentrée du 7 septembre
2012 de l'ordre et solennelle de la cour
des comptes en rappelant bien
l'engagement de la france de ramener le
déficit à 3% à la fin de l'année 2013 et
il précisait et là je le cite le
ralentissement économique actuel rend
encore plus ardue la réalisation de cet
objectif mais encore plus nécessaire et
la réussite de cet exercice
pierre moscovici avait à l'occasion de
la présentation d'une loi de finance des
projets de loi de finances pour 2013
indiqué à notre commission des finances
et je m'en souviens et je le cite là
aussi c'est bien pour nous de 3% dont il
s'agît pas 3,1 pour cent pas 3,2 pour
cent pas 3% tendance pas 3% à peu près
pas 3% si on peut mais 3%
fin de citation et à l'arrivée cela a
été en effet pas à peu près 3% mais 4,3
pour cent des déficits
en réalité en 2013 comme cette année ne
garnements fans de croix ou fans nous
faire croire que cette limite allait
être respectée alors même que
l'opposition parlementaire
ici même on s'était exprimée alors même
que la cour des comptes alors même qu'à
des différents organismes alors même que
les observateurs alors même que les
instituts de conjoncture tous n'y
croyais pas pas plus sans doute selon
toute vraisemblance que le gouvernement
lui-même en 2013 en effet les
perspectives avait été radicalement
révisé mais tout de même je le dis en
bonne intelligence avec la commission
européenne et le ministre des finances
et des comptes publics a donné avec vous
monsieur le ministre d'ailleurs une
conférence de presse le 10 septembre
dernier au cours de laquelle vous avez
indiqué que vous souhaitiez adressé à
disco
vérité en fait cela sonne plus comme un
repentir au regard des engagements
antérieurs et est-ce que c'est à dire
que les prévisions précédentes étaient
bonnes au moment du programme de
stabilité ou au moins au début du débat
sur la loi d'orientation des publics des
finances publiques
il s'est agit tout simplement en fait de
mettre subitement au nos partenaires
européens devant le fait accompli
comment ces derniers comment ces
derniers peuvent-ils alors qu'ils ont
mis en oeuvre dans les différents pays
les programmes de rigueur comment
peuvent-ils accepter que nous d'accès
nous mettions en place des mesures qui
ne finalement représente une forme
d'arrogance udine littéralisme qui n'a
en tous les cas pas conforme ni à
l'esprit ni à les lettres de la manse et
l'intégration européenne
quand je peux comprendre que ce soit
engagée dans une logique de rapport de
force avec la commission plu puis sautez
hausser le ton mais n'est-ce pas
finalement un peu manqué de respect à
l'égard de nos engagements à l'égard de
nos partenaires
comment peut-on croire que cette
grandeur c'est hard ans impressionne des
pays comme les grecs comme les espagnols
comme les portugais comme les pays
baltes qu'amazon deux pays qui eux ont
fait des efforts considérables et sous
une pression constante à laquelle nous
n'avons pas contribué si le doit résumer
en fait nous n'avons respecté aucun de
nos engagements
après avoir obtenu un report de 2013 à
nous avons unilatéralement décidé
l'objectif de reporter l'objectif de 3%
de déficit à 2017
nous n'avons pas mis en oeuvre
l'ajustement structurel demandé par la
commission européenne pour les années
2014 et 2015
nous avons modifié sans motif valable
notre objectif à moyen terme de solde
structurel
enfin nous avons privé de tout effet le
mécanisme de correction et comme l'a
souligné le président du haut conseil
didier migaud que nous recevions conseil
des finances publiques nous recevions le
15 novembre dernier le 15 octobre
dernier en commission et bien le
président du haut-conseil nous disait la
correction elle a consisté tout
simplement en une
nouvelle loi de programmation ainsi
concrètement le gouvernement a décidé en
quelque sorte d'effacer l'ardoisé et les
écarts passé avec une nouvelle loi de
programmation des finances publiques qui
abroge tout simplement les orientations
de la précédente
et finalement ce que nous sommes au
parlement cela interroge sur la portée
du travail de l'islate heures il semble
si simple d'échapper à la correction
alors en termes de soldes effectifs sur
les années 2013 à 2015 et la dérive par
rapport à la loi de programmation de
décembre 2012 devrait atteindre 3% du
pib
alors où en sommes nous aujourd'hui eh
bien vous le savez le déficit de 2015
sera tout simplement le même que celui
de 2013
cela montre tout simplement l'échec ou
la renonciation à la politique de
redressement des comptes et des finances
publiques qui est menée depuis le début
du quinquennat
et force est de constater qu'elle n'a
pas produit de résultats la plaie de
produits l'exaspération
mais elle n'a pas produit les résultats
attendus alors tout ça est certainement
inquiétant mais je le dirai ça l'est
encore plus si l'on se compare aux
autres pays européens
en effet un petit chiffre qui méritent
d'être rappelés la france affiche est
afficherait un déficit de 4 4% du pib en
2014 contre une moyenne de 2,6 pour cent
de la zone euro et nous figurons vous le
savez parmi les états européens qui y
ont un niveau de déficits les plus
élevés trois cas que deux pays qui nous
dépasse le portugal avec 4,9 pour cent
et l'espagne avec 5,6 pour cent du pib
mais ces pays il est vrai parts de
beaucoup plus loin
ils n'ont eu en tout cas ils ont passé
budgétaire plus lourd et ils ont fait
des efforts beaucoup plus importants
je vous rappelle que l'espagne avait un
déficit de près de 10% du pib en 2011 et
le portugal de plus de 7% alors que nous
avions nous à l'époque 5% donc sa mesure
le chemin parcouru par ces pays et alors
que même nous avions purement simplement
stagné puisqu'une autre déficit
disais à l'instant est tout simplement
le même que en 2013 alors une telle
situation ne serait surprendre alors que
le gouvernement affirme avoir procédé à
un effort considérable c'est une
citation il apparaît que la dépense
publique en france a tout simplement
progressé de 2 5% en moyenne entre 2012
et 2013
et pourtant elle n'avait elle a
progressé que de 1,2 pour cent dans les
autres pays
de là-haut en moyenne dans la de zone
euro à 2 2% de progression en moyenne
sur deux ans dans la zone euro et en
france de 8 5 % de la dépense publique
en progression s'explique le
différentiel avec les autres pays alors
maintenant j'en viens après ce petit
historique
j'en viens plus précisément à la
nouvelle trajectoire celle qui nous est
proposé dans cette loi de programmation
de pour les années 2014 2019
que nous dit le gouvernement quelles
sont les grandes lignes premièrement
c'est le premier prix un désaccord mais
ce ministre
cette loi programmation reporte une
nouvelle fois je les dis leur tour un
déficit effectifs à 3% du l'objectif
c'est reporter 2015 17 et se reporte
également l'objectif de moyen terme
alors que nous devions en effet revenir
à l'équilibré structurel en 2016 nous
visons désormais à déficit structurel de
-0 4 2 004 ses déficits en 2019 et le
décalage est à cet égard considérable
mais surtout c'est ce que nous avons
protesté dans l'examen en commission la
plus large partie de l'effort repose sur
la fin de la période c'est à dire sur la
prochaine législature et aucune
inflation informations les données sur
l'ajustement qui devrait être effectué
en 2018 et 2019 ce qui peut se
comprendre puisque c'est la prochaine
législature mais cela représente tout de
même 40 milliards d'euros d'économies
qui sont simplement évoqué pas documenté
à ce stade laissant donc au prochain la
prochaine législature au prochain
gouvernement le soin d'en définir le
contenu ça veut dire tout simplement que
près de la moitié du chemin à parcourir
devrait l'être après 2017
ce qui monte en quelque sorte déjà une
forme d'échec par rapport aux ambitions
initiales en tous les cas celle de la
pressée de l'après présente liste nature
en second lieu et c'est une des raisons
pour laquelle nous sommes en désaccord
fondamental avec la trajectoire la
programmation et réaffirme l'objectif
d'une baisse des dépenses publiques de
50 milliards d'euros entre 2015 et 2017
évidemment on peut être d'accord mais
malheureusement pratique c'est le seul
point 2 finalement qui demeure stable et
avec bien sûr des certain nombre de
dépenses nouvelles et d'allègement de
prélèvements obligatoires
mais c'est un paradoxe alors
qu'initialement les 50 milliards d'euros
d'économies étaient un moyen pour nous
permettre d'atteindre des objectifs de
soldes elle constitue désormais une fin
en soi est pour ainsi dire c'est
l'objectif majeur du gouvernement
la difficulté c'est que depuis la
définition des sept objectifs il ya
bientôt un an
les lignes ont bougé et le gouvernement
nous annonce notamment en matière de
fiscalité non plus 50 milliards d'euros
mais qu'il faudrait bien davantage à la
vérité quand on lit dans notre
programmation
personne ne sait comment retrouver ces
50 milliards d'économies à supposer
qu'ils aient un sens le tendancielle en
effet par rapport auquel ils ont été
appréciés a été modifié et les décomptes
du gouvernement nous laisse du mois en
commission pour le moins sceptique on
nous promet de tout dire mais il faut
bien le reconnaître c'est d'ailleurs
aussi ce qui nous a bien peu la cour des
comptes
nous n'avons pas toutes les pièces du
puzzle on se demande en constatant que
comment on peut y arriver d'ailleurs
parce que nier la commission
manifestement ni le haut conseil des
finances publiques ni d'ailleurs les
médias n'ont réussi à relever ce défi
et d'ailleurs le ministre des finances
et des comptes publics indiqué au début
du mois de septembre qui ne serait pas
possible
finalement de faire les 21 milliards
d'euros d'économies prévues pour 2015
parce que l'inflation était trop faible
et il faudrait deux jours plus tard il
s'est ravisé en indiquant que ces deux
milliards d'économies ne serait seront
pas réalisés à cause de la copas de
l'inflation mais qu'elles seront
compensés on a un petit peu d'hésitation
et un petit peu de mal à comprendre
est ce que c'est une alternative est ce
que c'est un impact sur le monde réel où
est ce qu'il s'agit simplement d'une
question de discours
est-ce que bref ces deux milliards
d'économies qui semble manquer dans le
décompte sont des économies sur la
protection sociale c'est peut-être pour
ça que ça nous échapperons commission
des finances bref il faudrait nous
expliquer la réalité de la situation
alors pour être en mesure de porter une
appréciation que nous allons faire dans
quelques instants sur la programmation
proposée par le gouvernement
il convient en premier lieu de regarder
un critère essentiel qui est celui de la
crédibilité et dans le contexte j'ai
rappelé tout à l'heure nous ne pourrions
pas nous permettre de présenter une
programmation qui ne serait pas solide
et réaliste
c'est vrai de ce point de vue je le
reconnai volontier certains progrès ont
été réalisés et les hypothèses de
croissance sont notamment plus en ligne
avec celle des principaux organismes
internationaux avec les instituts de
conjoncture que nous avons sollicités
s'agissant des hypothèses de croissance
elles apparaissent plus réaliste que par
le passé
c'est sans doute on suit plus l'avis du
haut conseil des finances publiques mais
le gouvernement c'est vrai un dumas l'a
éprouvé à se départir d'une forme d'un
d'optimiste c'est le mot employé
le président du haut conseil en disant
que la prévision de croissance pour 2015
et est optimiste c'est son au terme et
il a jugé que le scénario est connu m
can be du garnement pour les années 2016
2017 était plus réaliste celui que le
précédent mais que ça continuer à
reposer sur des hypothèses trop
favorable sur l'environnement
international et sur l'investissement et
par ailleurs vous le savez le produit
conseil a rappelé que en ce qui concerne
les dépenses les économies étaient peu
documentée bref cet optimiste il est
vrai doit être mesurée au regard des
excès du passé
c'est une première limite à la
crédibilité la trajectoire
ce n'est sans doute pas à mes yeux la
plus importante la plus importante c'est
tout simplement la faiblesse des
économies structurelles qui rend très
hasardeuse le respect de la trajectoire
si l'on se réfère au projet doivent
financière pour 2015 la plupart des
mesures d'économie on aura l'occasion
d'y revenir très largement dans le plf
ressemblent plus à des mesures de coup
de rabot de bouclage budgétaire beaucoup
plus qu'à des choix et à des économies
structurelles pour le reste il s'agit en
effet d'une logique de coupe de 2002
baisses de plafond des armes
d'organismes bref tout le monde est mis
un petit peu à contribution sur mesure
sous couvert de mesures d'optimisation
de rationalisation d'amélioration de la
productivité
nous préférions point d'autre part des
mesures de choix de choix courageux de
la forme d'une structure plutôt que des
petits coups de rabots là et là ce n'est
malheureusement pas l'orientation qui
est prise par le gouvernement
la hausse des crédits mis en réserve
laisse en effet à penser on ne vous
l'avait évoqué monsieur le ministre
sur les 8 % là c'est en effet à penser
que le ghana on n'a pas tout à fait fini
les avantages budgétaires au moment ils
préparaient présenté la loi de finances
est par ailleurs le projet de loi
prévoit location prévoit la mise en
place de revues dépenses pourquoi pas ça
me semble en effet très pertinent
d'avoir des vrais des revues de défense
pour l'instant c'est un petit peu vague
et sept moines peut-être à ce stade-là
difficulté ou la capacité du
gouvernement à documenter ou du mois à
choisir des économies structurelles un
mot ce monsieur le ministre mesdames et
présente mes chers collègues sur le
finalement le sort que nous allons
réserver à cette loi de programmation
nous allons concrètement
si j'ai bien compris nous prononcer sur
vos habib sur vos amendements de
rétablissement puisque nous avons en
commission supprimer les articles
relatives à la programmation
je crois que vous allez nous proposer de
les rétablir de rétablir
c'est tout à fait dans votre logique un
regret simplement à partir du moment où
vous prononce proposer leur
établissement la trajectoire
nous aurions souhaité que vous attiriez
les 3,6 milliards d'euros
sinon la loi de programmation est d'ores
et déjà un petit peu caduque obsolète et
on plutôt que de rétablir comment
simplement le texte intégré les 3,6
milliards dans la trajectoire
ça aurait été plus respectueux du
parlement alors enfin bref mot sur donc
c'est la commission des finances
concrètement à contenu des accords
fondamentaux que j'ai exprimée sur la
programmation décidé évidemment de
maintenir le refus de ces orientations
et qui figure dans les amendements que
vous allez rétablir tout à l'heure mais
nous allons avoir un débat vous l'avez
évoqué tout à fait intéressant sur le
projet de loi tel qu'il est modifiée par
la commission des finances puisque je le
dis clairement sur la partie gouvernance
il y à des avancées que je considère
utiles que nous souhaitons pour notre
part amélioré en se remettant bien sûr
que souhaitant qu'elles soient mises en
oeuvre
ça permettra si elles sont mises en
oeuvre d' améliorer bien sûr la
gouvernance des finances publiques est
d'améliorer également l'information du
parlement c'est pour ça que nous avons
se décider bien sûr d'adopter des
articles sur la partie concernant les
normes et la gouvernance des finances
publiques merci de votre attention
merci monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre vous avez la parole
merci madame la présidente
l'un de vos collègues ayant considéré
que je m'endormais pendant le discours
est l'ayant dit à voix haute permettrait
de voir des suspensions de séance de 10
minutes en termes de protestation parce
que je trouve c'est particulièrement
discourtois
bien la science est suspendue pour
quelques minutes monsieur le ministre je
préside madame la présidente pardon ce
ministre mes chers collègues le
parlement examine donc un projet de loi
de programmation des finances publiques
pour la 4e fois depuis 2008 et votre
commission des affaires sociales c'en
est bien évidemment saisi pour avis en
raison de la part que prennent ces
finances au sein des finances publiques
en 2013 les dépenses des administrations
de sécurité sociale représente 27% de
notre richesse nationale 46 et demi pour
cent des dépenses publiques et 53,6 %
des prélèvements obligatoires et un
déficit de 10 milliards d'euros
j'allais dire seulement les seulement
regard des dizaines de milliards que
représente le déficit du budget de
l'état
alors pardon les lois de programmation
sont aussi désormais l'outil de
vérification pour le parlement pardon
des engagements européens de la france
qui sont je le rappel des objectifs que
nous nous sommes donnés collectivement
je serais bref sur la partie
programmatique de ce texte
notre collègue albéric de montgolfier
rapporteur général de la commission des
finances l'a très bien décrite et je
partage son analyse sur cette partie
notre commission a principalement
examiner les variables qui intéresse les
finances sociales que sont la croissance
du pib et l'évolution de la masse
salariale du secteur privé
si nous considérons la période au delà
de la première année de programmation
l'hypothèse du projet de loi de
programmation est celle d'une croissance
de 1,9 pour cent en moyenne
à compter de 2016 avec une progression
annuelle de 4% de la masse salariale
privée
ce sont effectivement les niveaux de
croissance de la masse salariale
observée avant la crise sur la période
98 2007
nous observons par un simple contrôle de
cohérence que pour une hypothèse de
croissance plus élevé le gouvernement
avait retenu le même taux d'évolution de
cette masse salariale au cours de la
précédente programmation est un peu
féministe comme si nous devions
invariablement revenir à ce taux
d'évolution sans préjudice des dégâts
d'une crise persistante que cette crise
a pu causer à notre appareil productif
alors quel est notre point d'entrée en
programmation
le déficit des administrations de
sécurité sociale a atteint 2013 zéro
point et demi de pib soit environ 10
milliards sont je rappelle que ce solde
comprend des administrations de sécurité
sociale qui par nature sont en excédent
soit parce qu'elles ont vocation à
couvrir des engagements futurs comme le
fonds de réserve des retraites soit paca
parce qu'elles sont chargées d' amortir
la dette comme la cades est ce donc
orcades sfr le sol des deux moins 20
milliards 6 soit 1 point de pib et 300
ce 3,65 cents de dépenses et le des
visites social n'est bien sûr pas
comparable ni en volume ni en part de
richesse nationale avec celui de l'état
mais la nature des dépenses n'est pas
non plus la même le déficit et surtout
la dette sociale constitue bien une
anomalie
j'ajoute aussi que l' équilibre de la
sécurité sociale n'est pas hors de
portée
l'exercice 2008 a ainsi révélé un
excédent de 0 7% du pib par rapport à ce
point d'entrée le projet de loi vise à
redressement du solde des
administrations de sécurité sociale très
significatif sur la période de
programmation
l' équilibre des comptes sociaux serait
retrouvé en 2016 avec un excédent de 0 3
point de pib en 2010 est donc là où
l'effort ça la différence là où l'effort
était répartie sur toute la période de
programmation dans la loi précédente
il est désormais plus concentré et
accéléré en fin de période
évidemment c'est plus facile un
croisement des tours de recettes et de
dépenses interviendrait ainsi en 2016 à
la faveur d'une trajectoire assez
spectaculaire de réduction des dépenses
en point de pib -0 2 point à 5
en trois ans le principal instrument de
pilotage
selon dame avec une progression de 2% en
moyenne et une augmentation de 3
milliards 8 d'euros chaque année
cet objectif est intenable
notre commission pense même qu'il est
possible de ralentir davantage la
dépense sans porter atteinte à la
performance de notre système de soins
à condition bien sûr de ne pas
s'interdire des réformes nécessaires
pour renforcer ce pilotage
elle a proposé d'augmenter le taux de
mise en réserve au même taux que celui
des dépenses de personnel de l'état
si l'on regarde la trajectoire
financière dans le détail nous
passerions d'un déficit social de 10
milliards cent en 2013 un excédent en
2010 est de 6 milliards cinq pour
l'ensemble des administrations de
sécurité sociale
l'évolution des autres administrations
de sécurité sociale hors champ du plfss
n'est pas détaillé elle comprend des
organismes aussi divers que l'ircantec
que tout le monde connaît bien où la
caisse de retraite de l'opéra pour ne
citer que ces exemples et continuent à
représenter l'angle mort de la vision du
parlement c'est pour notre commission
le principal enjeu de la partie relative
au pilotage des finances publiques
j'en viens donc à la deuxième partie du
texte qui porte sur des mesures de
pilotage des finances publiques et de
bonne gouvernance
pour ce qui concerne particulièrement
les administrations de sécurité sociale
le gouvernement propose de renforcer le
contrôle des ars sur les établissements
de santé soumis à un plan de
redressement
nous partageons su dominer cet objectif
le gouvernement se propose également de
remettre un rapport au parlement sur
l'évolution des dépenses de personnel
des hôpitaux en détaillant les mesures
catégorielles votre commission des
affaires sociales a souhaité enrichir ce
rapport d'éléments sur les autres
déterminant de la dépense hospitalière
et de détailler leur impact dans
l'organe dans un second article
spécifique
le gouvernement se propose encore une
fois de remettre un rapport au parlement
dans un texte qui en compte déjà un
certain nombre et il s'agit cette fois
d'un rapport sur l'assurance chômage que
notre commission avait recommandé de
supprimer autant les déterminants des
dépenses hospitalières sont mal connus
autant les données sur la situation
financière de l'unedic qui publie ces
chiffres
trois fois par an ne font pas défaut au
demeurant rien n'empêche le gouvernement
de faire connaître son analyse de la
situation financière de l'assurance
chômage
en l'absence de ce rapport donc si la
situation financière de l'unedic nous
est connue la façon dont le gouvernement
l'intègre non seulement dans la
programmation mais encore dans le solde
des administrations de sécurité sociale
ne l'est en revanche pas clairement nous
retrouvons ce débat sur les 9 milliards
6,2 d'économie en 2015 pour lesquels la
part de l'assurance chômage et des
retraites complémentaires est aussi
significatif que mal identifié nous
avons donc besoin plfss après plfss et
pas seulement de la loi de programmation
lors plutôt de la loi de programmation
d'une décomposition du solde structurel
des différentes administrations
publiques y compris donc
des administrations de sécurité sociale
s'agit là d'un élément essentiel de
pilotage des finances publiques
quelle est la contribution des
administrations de sécurité sociale à
l'effort structurel à l'effort de
recettes et à l'effort de dépenses c'est
ce que nous souhaiterions suivre année
après année au sein même des
administrations de sécurité sociale
comme je le disais précédemment subsiste
des angles morts pour la vision du
parlement c'est pourquoi nous souhaitons
pouvoir bénéficier du détail des
dépenses des recettes et du solde de la
dette de l'ensemble des administrations
de sécurité sociale
en l'absence de texte le gouvernement
pourrait enrichir les annexes du plfss
relatives au financement qui contiennent
un certain nombre d'éléments essentiels
sur le solde structurel
ce n'est pas la loi de finances sociales
proposées par la cour des comptes
mais ce serait déjà un élément
indispensable à l'information du
parlement toujours sur cette question de
l'information du parlement et dans la
continuité du rapport qui nous a été
remis par la cour des comptes sur les
relations conventionnelles entre
l'assurance maladie et les professions
libérales de santé
nous avons souhaité alors que les
relations sont le vecteur de diffusion
de l'ondam soins de ville que le
parlement soit informée des orientations
de ces négociations
si ces éléments sont maintenus nous
aurons progressé dans le contrôle
démocratique des finances sociales et
votre commis commission considèrera ce
texte comme une véritable avancée voilà
monsieur ministre sous le bénéfice de
toutes ces observations
il nous a semblé que la programmation
pluriannuelle proposée par le
gouvernement
reposer sur des hypothèses trop
optimiste qui font peser des
incertitudes très forte et des aléas
trop important sur son exécution
les recettes ne seront vraisemblablement
pas au rendez vous
malgré ces hypothèses pourtant les
objectifs de retour à l'équilibré sont
repoussés sans que les mesures fortes
qui serait nécessaire un véritable
redressement soit identifiée en revanche
en revanche la partie relative au
pilotage comporte des avancées
intéressantes qui vont dans le sens
d'une gestion plus rigoureuse
notre commission y voit l'occasion
d'enrichir l'information du parlement et
de lui permettre en particulier une
vision plus complète du sous secteur des
administrations de sécurité sociale pour
la partie située hors du périmètre du
projet de loi de financement
c'est pourquoi votre commission affaires
sociales a donné un avis défavorable sur
la partie programmatique du projet est
favorable sur la partie relative au
pilotage des finances publiques
voilà mes chers collègues nous sommes
prêts monsieur le ministre mes
conclusions et le remercie de votre
attention
merci monsieur le rapporteur la parole
est à madame michèle andré présidente de
la commission des finances madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues nous examinons la
quatrième loi de programmation des
finances publiques catégorie de loi
introduite dans notre constitution par
la révision constitutionnelle de 2008 le
volet du projet de loi relatif à la
gouvernance a été modifié par la
commission des finances
mais globalement dans l'esprit qui a
présidé aux travaux sur la loi organique
de décembre 2012 sur la programmation et
la gouvernance des finances publiques
il a fait l'objet d'un large accord
d'ailleurs aucun amendement ne propose
de revenir sur les apports de la
commission des finances dans ce domaine
cela étant dit l'expérience des trois
précédentes lois de programmation nous
montre que beaucoup de règles ambitieuse
n'ont pas été mises en oeuvre et nous
devrons être plus sourcilleux dans le
suivi de l'application des lois de
programmation
quoi qu'il en soit une gouvernance
sophistiqués n'a jamais à elle seule
permis d'améliorer la situation des
finances publiques
et j'en viens maintenant on voulait du
texte consacré à la programmation la
programmation des finances publiques
qu'elles soient exprimés en solde
structurel ou en soldes effectifs permet
au parlement d'approuver un chemin pour
l'ensemble des finances publiques c'est
à dire à la fois de l'état des
administrations sociales et des
administrations locales
par delà la segmentation de nos débats
budgétaires en plusieurs textes
financiers
politiquement c'est là que se trouve
désormais l'enjeu comme l'ont montré les
échanges récents avec la commission
européenne dans le cadre de la nouvelle
procédure d'examen par la commission des
plans budgétaires nationaux et c'est
donc un élément déterminant de notre
stratégie économique qui est aujourd'hui
proposé à notre vote
ce débat sera l'occasion pour le
gouvernement d'indiquer comment la
programmation devra être ajusté au cours
de la navette pour tenir compte des
mesures supplémentaires annoncées par le
ministre des finances ce débat permettra
aussi j'espère à la majorité sénatoriale
de nous faire connaître sa position sur
des aspects essentiels de la stratégie
de finances publiques
je connais les objections de la majorité
sénatoriale sur la programmation du
gouvernement mais je ne sais pas quelles
sont ces options revenir à un niveau
proche de l'équilibré structurel en 2019
ou bien plutôt ramener le déficit
effective sous le seuil de 3% du pib en
2010 cette houle bien avant s'il faut le
faire avant quels sont les efforts
supplémentaires qu'il faudrait consentir
en recettes comment dépenses je n'oublie
pas la question des collectivités
locales et notre débat nous permettra
aussi en tout cas je l'espère d'en
savoir plus sur la manière dans la
majorité du sénat envisage la question
de la baisse des dotations
j'attends donc beaucoup de ce débat sur
une programmation qui me paraît pour ma
part convaincante à la fois
politiquement et économiquement
voilà pour le début de l'examen de ce
projet de loi de programmation des
finances publiques pour la période
1014 à 2019 un texte qui fixe les
grandes orientations budgétaires pour
les cinq prochaines années les dépenses
et les recettes pour l'état les
collectivités territoriales mais aussi
la sécurité sociale et vous avez pu
l'entendre et bien la france va devoir
prévoir de grandes économies des
économies encore jugée insuffisante par
la droite
vous pouvez toujours voir et revoir
toutes les séances notre site
publicsenat.fr prochain rendez vous de
l'actualité parlementaire à 15 heures
pour les questions cribles consacré au
logement étudiant très bonne journée sur
les chaînes parlementaires